[Music]
how do we say no to family members who
think we're being snobby and standoffish
simply because we don't want to
participate in gift giving games
especially when it involves mostly
useless trinkets
so being snobby and standoffish is one
thing so the first question i have to
ask myself and i am especially prone to
this
not the snobby part but the standoffish
part because i've set boundaries for
myself and i i know what i like i know
what i dislike
and if i tolerate what i dislike enough
people keep giving me what i dislike
and so whatever you tolerate you will
get more of
but i have to be careful to not be
standoffish why did you get for this for
me what are you doing you know i told
you no christmas gifts this year
whatever it is right
because doing that
actually escalates the problem doesn't
it yeah
man you know
like this sounds like a white elephant
type
game that's where like you you like
you're constantly swapping gifts right
is the gift exchange yes is that the
what elephant thing so a white elephant
thing is where on the office they call
it yankee swap okay all right what is
what elephant it's a group a group of
people understand it is it's a group of
people where they they all buy a gift
that's under x dollars maybe it's under
50 or under 25 or whatever and then i
give you a gift and you give shawn a
gift
and then shawn gives danny a gift and
danny gives alabama a gift okay alabama
we all give jordan no more
watches that's right
no i i okay so i forget what the game is
called and maybe our live stream can
remind me of the game but it's where
everyone brings a gift that's like yeah
x amount of dollars or less
you wrap it up
you start you like roll the die whoever
i don't know how you decide what the die
roll but i remember dice being involved
and let's say you get to go first you
get to pick a gift and open it up the
next person goes they can either steal
your gift
or they can pick another gift unwrapped
unwrap it wow so it just continues to go
on i don't know how many rounds there
are again i forget what it's called
dirty sound that's what it is it is
called dirty santa oh bex and i play
dirty sand that's a completely different
game
well you could make it in any game you
want but anyway here's what i would say
about that because this is literally
they're talking about a game gift giving
games
so in a gift-giving game honestly
i would participate in that and to me it
wouldn't matter what i get as much as
what i give
so what are you bringing to the gift
giving game a you might be able to set
an example for like the next time they
do that like hey maybe it's a box of
chocolate maybe a consumable maybe it's
an experience whatever it is but maybe
you end up with a wanna hump t-shirt
so what go give it to the give her the
either give it back to the hey this was
a fun game
it was great we laughed we drunk eggnog
whatever uh hey i'm not gonna really
actually wear this shirt you want this
back right or like i'll be happy to drop
this off with a donation center for you
right and you can do that without being
a snob you can now you can also take it
a step farther as you said if you
participate in a way that you want to
participate maybe you're gifting
experiences or consumables maybe that's
setting a tone for next year or maybe
this year maybe it's not too late that
you and your friends who are
participating in this game you can all
agree hey we're going to do this
boundaries we're only going to gift
consumables that would be awesome we're
only going to give consumables or
experiences can we play this with the uh
the minimalist team
we can but there would be experiences
like concert tickets sporting events
movie passes theater tickets golf passes
community theater restaurant gift cards
indoor rock climbing bowling passes
summer camp a hot air balloon ride shout
out to joshua becker for that list of 52
clutter free gifts dude we should play
this game record it and give it to our
patrons
yes
mallory and i will be excited i see what
you're saying yeah yeah yeah and we can
just do it with just consumables or uh
or memberships
now the prizes have to be a million
dollars or less nothing over a million
dollars okay guys
[Music]
so you there are other things you can
you can go go with as well classes
um so you can also you can donate your
time yeah it can even be to a charity or
something like that or massages i'm
getting massages for everyone i'm going
to give 10 free hugs
consensual hugs
[Laughter]
always the caveats with you
but
i think the point is here we can set
these boundaries beforehand we can now
is the time to get their buy-in before
you buy all the gifts now maybe not
everyone's going to buy into that but
guess what if you have a group of 10
people or how many do we have here
there's there's six of us in the room
right now
let's say five of us bought in and then
you know jordan is like no i want to
make sure that i give you you know
pajama overall
onesie okay fine the gym overall onesie
patent pending all right continue
it's fine that he does that right but
he will then feel like the outcast at
this one not that we want him to feel
like an outcast right but if everyone
else or the majority of people bought
into yes i enjoy the experiences or i
enjoy memberships consumables something
like that
great
and then there are a few people who want
to give material items okay we're not
going to shun you but understand that we
set up a boundary beforehand yeah
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free